في الولايه الشماليه بالسودان تحديدا في
مدينه مروي يبدو المشهد متوترا وقد ياخذ
البلاد الى هويه العنف عقب الحشود الاخيره
لقوات الدعم السريع التي قبلها الجيش
بتحرك مماثل المدينه الواقعه على الضفه
الجنوبيه للنهر النيل تحتوي على مطار دولي
واحدى اهم القواعد الجويه للجيش السوداني
التوتر الذي تشهده المدينه جاء بعد حشد
قوات الدعم السريع قرابه 100 اليه عسكريه
تحديدا في محيط القاعده الجويه جنوب
المدينه امر دفع الجيش السوداني الى تحشيد
قواته في القاعده الجويه ومحيطها
الجيش السوداني اعتبر تحرك الدعم السريع
مخالفا للقانون ويضع البلاد في منعطف وصفه
بالخطير والتاريخ الى سيما انه جرى دون
موافقته هذه الانفتاحات واعاده تمركز
القوات
يخالف مهام ونظام عمل قوات الدعم السريع
وفيه تجاوز واضح
للقانون ومخالفه لتوجيهات اللجان الامنيه
المركزيه والولائيه واستمرارها سيؤدي حتما
الى المزيد من الانقسامات والتوترات التي
ربما تقود الى انفراط عقد الامن بالبلاد
تقول المعلومات ان القوات الدعم السريعه
تريد الانقضاض على المطار العسكري الاهم
للجيش في الشمال لافشال اي تحرك جوي للجيش
وعبر سلاح الطيران اذا وقعت المواجهه
منذ مطلع الشهر الجاري بدا الجيش ببناء
السور ومرافق في الارض المحاذيه لمطار
المدينه امر قد يفسر سبب تحرك قوات الدعم
السريع التي يقودها حميدتي ومع توارد
الانباء عما تشهده ماروي بدات القوى
السياسيه والمدنيه تحركات المكوكيه
لاحتواء الموقف موقف منصف بالخطير ووصل
مرحله ما قبل الطلقه الاولى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات